bueno el
haití está ubicado
unión podría deciros y de la de la
convergencia de la placa atlántica con
la placa caribeña
la subducción de la placa atlántica bajo
la placa caribeña genera la isla de las
antillas menores todo esa isla volcánica
martinica también y si yo que han tenido
una historia de erupciones importantes y
la fuerza llega hasta hasta puerto rico
o una de las más profundas y de ahí se
une hacia américa central méxico
mediante una falla transformacional que
es el otro borde de placas hay tres
tipos de borde de placas los
convergentes los divergentes las
cordilleras de expansión oceánica los
convergentes son las zonas de subducción
como ocurre en las cosas de puerto rico
la de perú chile y los
transformacionales las trans corrientes
y esas son fallas casi verticales
con movimiento horizontal es
principalmente y eso es lo que ocurre en
la conexión de la
ardilla con méxico
que buscan terremotos de
baja profundidad llama la atención que
república dominicana que está en la
misma isla con haití comparten estos dos
estados este territorio de la isla de la
española
en república dominicana han sentido
estos sismos sintieron el del 2010
sintieron el de esta madre esta mañana
en haití pero parece que no lo afecta de
la misma manera cuáles son las
condiciones del oeste de esta isla que
tenga una posición tal vez más crítica y
propensa a que geológicamente salga más
afectada cuando se presentan eventos
sísmicos
sin la serie de fallas que
producen estos sismos están en la parte
sur de la isla que comparten república
dominicana y haití entonces
a ellos no les toca mucho
realmente los movimientos se producen en
estas fallas que están más en haití que
en república dominicana por decirlo así
y en movimiento son fuertes y además son
equipos centros de muy baja profundidad
lo cual hace que la intensidad del sismo
se sienta superficie muy fuertemente
señor michael dobbs muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y
explicar este tema para nuestra
audiencia en américa latina'